Fritz Haber made food from the air.
He invented a process that takes nitrogen
from the air and turns it into fertilizer.
This revolutionized agriculture and fed billions
of people who otherwise might have starved.
He became a hero in his native Germany and
won a Nobel prize.
Yet the man who fed billions also had a hand
in unspeakable atrocities.
Fritz Haber developed poison gas which was
then used on both sides in World War One.
His work led to the development of the devastating
use of gas during the Holocaust.
Haber himself was born to a Jewish family
in 1868 in Breslau, a city that was then part
of Germany but is now located in Poland and
is known as Wroclaw.
He grew up without his mother, who died weeks
after giving birth.
Fritz’s father, Siegfried was devastated.
He threw himself into his business and became
a prosperous dye merchant.
Siegfried eventually remarried and had three
daughters.
He doted on his girls but not on Fritz…who
was a reminder of the pain of losing his first
wife.
After Fritz graduated from an elite school
and celebrated with friends in a pub until
the wee hours of the morning, his dad was
not happy when he overslept and skipped family
breakfast.
Fritz’s father took his three girls to Fritz’s
bedroom and said: “Look well!
This is how the life of a drunkard begins!”.
That deeply hurt his son.
Fritz wanted out of his father’s house.
And out of Breslau.
He wanted to “break free of the chains that
wear me down…” as he wrote to a friend.
He decided to go to university to study chemistry;
he had already been conducting homemade experiments
at his aunt’s house.
He studied at several German universities
and earned a doctorate in organic chemistry
in 1891.
Haber also served a year in the military and
hoped to be commissioned as an officer in
the reserves, but he likely understood that
he was rejected because of his Jewish heritage.
He later converted to Christianity, possibly
to advance his career or to assimilate into
German society, where anti-Semitism was rising.
Rejection became part of his life.
When he applied to join the lab of the esteemed
physical chemist Wilhelm Ostwald in Leipzig,
his application was denied, while that of
his friend and fellow student, Richard Abegg,
was accepted.
No one appeared to recognize his brilliance.
He moved from job to job, working at factories
in Eastern Europe through his dad’s connections.
Finally, in 1894, at the age of 26, he was
hired as an assistant at the Technical University
of Karlsruhe, now the Karlsruhe Institute
of Technology, in the department of Chemical
and Fuel Technology.
The university wasn't renowned at the time,
but this worked in his favor, as his supervisors
gave him the freedom to pursue his own ideas.
When someone asked how he managed to master
a range of specialties in chemistry so quickly,
Haber replied that he “studied every night
until 2 am until I got it.”
Sometimes, he’d escape into sanatoriums
to calm his nerves.
He worked so hard that his wife, chemist Clara
Immerwahr wrote: “Fritz is so scattered,
if I didn’t bring him to his son every once
in a while, he wouldn’t even know that he
was a father.” (page 63)
Clara was also the child of a prosperous merchant.
She was also born to a Jewish family and later
converted to Christianity.
Because she couldn’t obtain good schooling
at a young age due to her gender, she made
up for it with private tutors.
At first, she was only allowed to attend university
as a guest, as women were not legally admissible
at the time.
When that policy changed, she became the first
woman in Germany to earn a Ph.D. in chemistry.
Yet her career was overshadowed by her husband’s;
she couldn’t advance in academia as she
was expected to fulfill the role of the professor’s
wife.
Fritz Haber was working at the university
when a British scientist issued a dire warning
in 1898.
Sir William Crookes warned that “England
and all civilized nations stand in deadly
peril of not having enough to eat.”
He focused his concern on the “bread-eaters
of the whole world”, the “great Caucasian
race”.
He predicted that the world would face famine
within decades unless a new source of nitrogen
for agricultural fertilizers could be found.
Nitrogen is a vital nutrient for plant growth.
Scientists relied on limited natural sources
of nitrogen to fertilize soil, such as animal
manure, bird and bat droppings, or sodium
nitrate from Chilean mines - but these resources
are limited.
Nitrogen is abundant in the atmosphere; 78%
of the air is made up of nitrogen.
However, in the way that humans can’t drink
saltwater, plants can’t use nitrogen directly
from the air as a source of nutrition, because
of its strong triple bond that makes it difficult
for plants to digest.
It must be converted into a more useful form.
Haber discovered that hydrogen breaks the
strong triple bond of nitrogen and converts
it to ammonia, or NH3, which is easier for
plants to absorb and use.
Ammonia is the raw material for common nitrogen-based
fertilizers, providing plants with essential
nutrients for growth, increasing crop yields
and food production.
Haber actually struggled at first to find
the point at which hydrogen and nitrogen atoms
combined into ammonia.
He almost gave up until a rival scientist
insulted him.
Walter Nernst said: “It is unfortunate that
so little ammonia is formed in this state
of equilibrium, compared with what Haber’s
highly inaccurate numbers led us to assume.”
That really ticked Haber off; he became obsessed
with obtaining ammonia before Nernst did.
Haber tried using extreme heat to encourage
the formation of ammonia, but that didn’t
work.
Even 1000 degrees Celsius only produced a
minuscule amount of ammonia: one-hundredth
of one percent.
Haber found an ally in Germany’s largest
chemical company BASF which gave him a generous
salary to pay for lab equipment and hire assistants.
In March 1909, he achieved a breakthrough
Haber used a catalyst, osmium, to accelerate
the chemical reaction between nitrogen and
hydrogen.
They combined to produce ammonia with a yield
of around 6%.
Haber had discovered a process akin to turning
lead into gold.
It would make him fabulously rich; BASF agreed
to pay him 1.5 pfennig - the German cent - in
royalties for each kilo of ammonia produced
- which added up to a significant sum as the
large-scale production of ammonia followed.
A chemist and engineer at BASF, Carl Bosch,
was responsible for scaling up and commercializing
the production of ammonia.
The process of synthesizing ammonia is known
worldwide as the Haber-Bosch process.
Today, an estimated 150 million metric tons
of nitrogen is extracted from the air annually,
transformed into ammonia, and distributed
as nourishing fertilizer for crops.
There are long-term environmental concerns
to consider.
Chemicals from these fertilizers can find
their way into water systems, harming water
quality and the surrounding ecosystems.
But without the Haber-Bosch process, it’s
likely that billions of people would not have
been able to obtain the food and nutrition
they need to survive.
About half of our planet’s seven billion
people are fed with crops grown using synthetic
fertilizers.
In 1911, two years after his groundbreaking
discovery, Haber became the founding director
of a prestigious new research institution,
the Kaiser Wilhelm Institute for Physical
Chemistry and Electrochemistry.
This photo shows Haber at the opening ceremony,
steps behind the German emperor and King of
Prussia, who lent his name to the institute.
Haber was now a member of the nation’s elite.
And Germany was a nation that had great ambition.
Haber was determined to support his country
in World War I, unlike Albert Einstein, who
was horrified that his fellow scientists used
their skills to help Germany's war effort.
Einstein the pacifist put it this way: “Our
entire much-praised technological progress,
and civilization generally, could be compared
to an axe in the hand of a pathological criminal.”
Haber's process for synthesizing ammonia also
enabled the creation of explosives.
Synthesized ammonia can be converted into
nitric acid, which can be used to create nitrates,
essential components in powerful explosives.
Because of Haber’s process, Germany could
fight on, despite British warships blocking
nitrate supplies from South America.
But explosives would not be Haber’s greatest
contribution to his country’s war effort.
Haber suggested to German military leaders
that they use chlorine gas as a weapon.
German High Command was willing to try anything
to break the stalemate on the Western front.
On April 22, 1915, German troops stationed
in Ypres, Belgium, released 5,000 tanks containing
chlorine gas which drifted across the battlefield
to Allied positions.
A British officer described the horror of
seeing French colonial soldiers “...with
gray faces and protruding eyeballs, clutching
their throats and choking as they ran, many
of them dropping in their tracks and lying
on the sodden earth with limbs convulsed and
features distorted in death.”
Soldiers panicked and abandoned their positions,
creating a four-mile gap in the frontline
that the Germans failed to exploit.
Several German commanders had actually opposed
using poison gas on the battlefield.
They thought it was a dishonorable and inhumane
way to fight as traditionally, soldiers faced
each other directly in combat.
Yet, Haber didn’t consider poison gas any
worse than bullets.
He argued, “...innumerable human lives would
be saved if the war could be ended more quickly
in this way.”
Unfortunately, it did not speed up the war.
As gas was heavily dependent on the way the
wind blew, and the Allies later used the same
weapon themselves.
Haber was promoted to the rank of captain
in recognition of his efforts in developing
chemical warfare.
It clearly went to his head.
The first president of Israel quoted him as
saying:
“I was one of the mightiest men in Germany.
I was more than a great army commander, more
than a captain of industry.
I was the founder of industries…All doors
were open to me”.
On April 1, 1915, Haber returned to Berlin
to celebrate his promotion
That same night, his wife shot herself with
his army pistol in their garden.
Their 12-year-old son Hermann found his dying
mother.
There’s been much speculation about why
Clara ended her own life.
Decades later, cousin Paul Krassa, wrote:
“She was in despair over the horrible consequences
of gas warfare, for which she’d seen the
preparations, along with the tests on animals.”
Clara had been miserable for a long time.
She struggled with the gender roles expected
of her, leaving her own ambitions to fall
by the wayside.
She detailed her suffering in a letter to
her mentor Richard Abegg, who had introduced
her to her husband.
“What Fritz has gained during these last
eight years, I have lost, and what's left
of me, fills me with the deepest dissatisfaction.”
Haber never publicly defended himself against
speculation that it was his work that caused
his wife’s death.
We got a glimpse of his emotional state when
he wrote to his former mentor, chemist Carl
Engler, six weeks later:
“For a month I doubted that I could keep
going.
But now the war, with its dreadful images
and constant demands on all my powers, has
made me calmer…”
A day after Clara took her own life, Haber
returned to the front lines.
He then supervised the development of an even
more horrific weapon – mustard gas.
Unlike chlorine gas, mustard gas didn’t
blow away with the wind and instead, stuck
to clothes, causing painful blisters and blinding
soldiers who got it in their eyes.
Haber called it a “fabulous success.”
By the end of the war, an estimated 90,000
soldiers had been killed by poison gas, and
more than a million suffered injuries.
Despite Haber’s efforts, Germany lost the
war.
The effectiveness of gas diminished as the
Allies started using the same weapon.
It didn’t help that Germany made a major
strategic blunder when it began to attack
both military and civilian ships without distinguishing
between the two, which brought the U.S. into
the war and tilted the balance of power.
After Germany surrendered, Haber worried that
he’d be tried as a war criminal.
He moved with his son, his second wife Charlotte,
and their young daughter to neutral Switzerland
for a time and even grew a beard as a disguise.
However, instead of being prosecuted for war
crimes, Haber was honored with the Nobel Prize
in Chemistry in 1919.
The Nobel Prize committee declared his synthesis
of ammonia "the greatest benefit to mankind”.
But the award was controversial because of
Haber’s development of chemical weapons.
Two French scientists who had been offered
prizes turned them down in protest.
Although he won the Nobel Prize, his legacy
is forever tarnished.
Haber failed to realize that his nation would
use his chemical weapon against innocent civilians.
The irony is that his own people, the Jewish
people, would become the primary victims.
The Nazis used Zyklon B to exterminate over
a million people in concentration camps in
World War Two.
Scientists at Haber’s Institute had developed
an earlier version of Zyklon to get rid of
insect infestations in flour mills and granaries.
Then they introduced another version of the
pesticide that was easier to handle and more
powerful without imagining it would ever be
used on people.
Haber’s own extended family perished in
Hitler’s gas chambers.
Anti-semitism grew after the first world war
as some Germans felt the Jewish people were
responsible for the country’s significant
problems.
Hitler’s Nazi party capitalized on the widespread
unemployment, poverty, and unrest to fuel
its rise to power.
Despite his contributions to his beloved Germany,
Haber realized he would soon become a target
of Nazi repression.
His conversion to Christianity was irrelevant;
it was his ancestry that mattered.
He was forced to fire some Jewish scientists
at his government-funded research institute
and, a few days later, Haber resigned his
own position in protest.
In his resignation letter to the Prussian
minister of culture, Haber emphasized his
lifelong principle: "My tradition requires
that when choosing coworkers for a scientific
post, I consider only the professional and
personal characteristics of the applicant,
without regard for their racial makeup."
“My tradition requires that when choosing
coworkers for a scientific post, I consider
only the professional and personal characteristics
of the applicant, without regard for their
racial makeup.
You cannot expect a man in his sixty-fifth
year to change the thinking that has guided
him for the past thirty-nine years of university
life, and you will understand that the pride
with which he served his German homeland all
his life now dictates this request for retirement.”
Planck appealed directly to Hitler, trying
to convince him that forcing valuable Jews
to leave would hurt Germany.
Hitler apparently flew into a rage.
Nazi policy left no room for exceptions, not
even for the man who had arguably contributed
more to Germany’s might during World War
I than anyone else.
Einstein, who had been traveling when the
Nazis came to power and declared he wouldn’t
return to Germany, put it this way in a letter
to Haber:
“I can imagine your inner conflicts.
It is somewhat like having to abandon a theory
on which you have worked your whole life.
It’s not the same for me as I never believed
in it in the least.”
Einstein put it more delicately in a letter
to Haber’s son after Haber’s death.
“It was the tragedy of the German Jew: the
tragedy of unrequited love.”
Haber tried his entire life to be the perfect
German.
Despite his religious conversion, despite
one of the greatest scientific discoveries
of all time, despite his attempt to save his
country, the only thing that mattered, in
the end, was that he was Jewish.
He summed up his feelings in a letter to the
prominent German chemist Richard Willstätter:
“I am bitter as never before, and the feeling
that this is unbearable increases by the day.”
As if it could not be any worse, Haber found
himself in a dire financial situation.
Hyperinflation after World War One had diminished
the value of his royalties from his ammonia
patents.
He also had to financially support his second
wife after their divorce.
The global financial crisis of 1929 ate away
what was left of his finances.
He desperately searched for a way out of his
precarious situation.
A former foe actually came to his rescue.
British chemist William Pope worked on the
development of gas warfare for the British
and offered Haber a temporary position at
the University of Cambridge.
By then, Haber’s health had worsened.
He eventually left England to seek treatment
at a sanatorium in Switzerland.
He got as far as Basel when his heart failed.
On the night of January 29, 1934, Fritz Haber
died.
He was 65 years old.
Haber had requested to his son Hermann that
this to be written on his gravestone:
“In war and peace, as long as it was granted
him, a servant of his homeland.”
Hermann refused his father’s wishes.
He also refused to attend his father’s memorial
service believed he couldn’t be honored
in the country that had rejected him.
Scientist Max Planck courageously organized
a service in Berlin on the one-year anniversary
of Haber’s death despite intimidation by
the Nazis, who ordered state employees to
stay away.
Many of the scientists' wives bravely attended.
The great industrialist Carl Bosch was also
there.
He owed his career to Haber.
The Haber-Bosch process led to the stunning
growth of Bosch's company, BASF, which later
merged with other chemical companies to form
the conglomerate I.G.
Farben which the Americans seized after WWII.
Although Haber tried to distance himself from
his Jewish heritage nearly his whole life,
in his final days, he seemed to have a change
of heart.
He struck up a friendship with the Zionist
Chaim Weizmann, who fought to establish the
state of Israel.
Haber lamented to Weizmann: “I was one of
the mightiest men in Germany…At the end
of my life I find myself a bankrupt.
When I am gone and forgotten your work will
stand, a shining monument, in the long history
of our people.”
Despite his significant contribution to the
field of chemistry, there is no statue of
Fritz Haber in Germany or anywhere.
The only place that bears his name is the
institute he once led.
The Kaiser Wilhelm Institute was renamed The
Fritz Haber Institute of the Max Planck Society
in 1953.
One of the institute’s directors said that
the name is a reminder that science can be
used as a tool for good and also as a tool
for evil.
Despite the controversy surrounding Fritz
Haber, his contributions to science have left
a lasting impact on the world
If you’d like to develop your own skills
in science, I highly recommend Brilliant.org,
a website and app where you can brush up on
your STEM skills.
My viewers really enjoy Brilliant’s Scientific
Thinking course, where you solve puzzles interactively
and build up the skills for making breakthroughs
in any scientific field.
Brilliant offers interactive courses in a
wide range of STEM subjects, including computer
science, data science, and math.
Their content is structured in a way where
you can dive deeper into advanced topics as
you progress, giving you an edge in your career.
I personally use Brilliant to help boost my
critical thinking skills through their logic
puzzles.
If you ever get stuck, you can view the explanation
to see where you went wrong.
Brilliant is free to try out for 30 days if
you head to the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up using
my link will get 20% off Brilliant’s Premium
subscription, which gives access to their
thousands of offerings.
Thanks for watching.
I’m Cindy Pom